I am the first woman
to be president of the European Commission.
I am the president of the European Commission.
And this is how I expected to be treated
when visiting Turkey two weeks ago,
like a commission president.
But I was not.
I cannot find any justification for what I was treated
in the European treaties.
Oh, I have to conclude that it happened
because I am a woman.
Would this have happened if I had worn a suit and a tie?
In the pictures of previous meetings,
I did not see any shortage of chairs.
But then again,
I did not see any women in these pictures, neither.
I felt hurt
and I felt alone as a woman and as a European,
because it is not about seating
arrangements or protocol.
This goes to the core of who we are.
This goes to the values our union stands for.
And this shows how far we still have to go
before women are treated as equals
always and everywhere.